pan overs idyllic old town the city
wants to make sure its visitors and
tourists don't miss a single sight or
attraction that's why they came up with
this little red line it runs four
kilometres through the city guiding you
to 36 of its most important sites
including plenty of examples of
Hanover's royal splendor this city was a
seat of royal power for more than 200
years home to the later Kings of Hanover
from one of Europe's oldest noble
families this was supposed to be their
new palace but the king of Hanover was
stripped of power by the Prussians in
1866 and never got to move in instead
the balance remained empty for ten years
until a university took over the
building hanover continued to grow in
size and splendor under Prussian rule -
with buildings like the new city hall
today it's become a landmark
curious visitors can take a tour
exploring its interior all the way up to
the roof from the dome visitors have a
tremendous panoramic view of Hannover
right in the heart of the city the
man-made mosh say Lake is one of Hanover
as many green oasis and so were the
banks of the liner River
the spacious Gorge garden as a landscape
park created in the English style and
it's a favorite among students
visitors taking a stroll through the
Royal Gardens are transported back to
the 17th century The Grocer garden or a
great garden
was the centerpiece of the electors
summer residence it was envisioned and
realized by Electress Sophia of Hanover
who wanted to create a sort of ballroom
outdoors the central focus of the garden
is this fountain which shoots over 80
metres into the sky for both locals and
visitors picnicking at the royal
residence is a special treat and don't
leave the Royal Gardens without seeing
the famous grotto designed by Nicky to
some five here the artist created a
magical world made of colorful mosaics
its accents like this that revealed a
modern face of Hanover was controversial
bananas sculptures are now an integral
part of the city Hannover has been
investing in open-air modern art since
the 1970s and some of it ends up in the
city's pedestrian zones whether taking
in the cultural attractions or relaxing
outdoors in its parks and gardens
Hanover is certain to delight
you